though they don't really have much to
say themselves
the zombies in the walking dead
definitely have a story
from production decisions to the makeup
and lore here's the truth
about those mysterious walkers
walkers in the walking dead are an
ever-present threat to every character
on the show but
they're a relatively manageable one it's
established early on in the series that
the walkers generally adhere to classic
tropes
for instance the undead hordes usually
only travel at a walking
pace there's a reason the show isn't
called the jogging
dead also despite the fact that zombie
bites cause the victims to turn into the
undead there are solutions to this
dilemma
such as when rick was able to prevent
herschel from turning by
severing his leg above the zombie bite
when a person turns into a walker they
lose almost all remnants of their former
self
high level thinking is unavailable to
them and while they might remember
small things like how to open doors
that's about it their driving force is
an
insatiable hunger for the flesh of
living things a drive that can't be
quelled
unless the brain of the walker is
destroyed
one of the biggest questions that's
plagued fans is
how exactly the zombie outbreak started
unfortunately neither the original
comics or the television series provide
concrete answers though he's been
reluctant to disclose the virus's root
cause in his works
walking dead author robert kirkman
apparently unveiled the genesis of the
zombie apocalypse on twitter
according to the now deleted tweet the
virus started from some sort of
space spore this explanation immediately
raised a few eyebrows and
considering kirkman's history of
inserting jokes about aliens as the
source of the zombie virus
that particular answer seemed a bit
suspect
though the space spore explanation
caused some curiosity
and debate it would soon be confirmed
that kirkman was once again playing a
prank on his fans
shortly after he deleted his initial
tweet confirming space spores started
the zombie outbreak
kirkman again took to twitter explaining
that he'd only been
joking ultimately the walking dead's
lack of an outbreak cause is most likely
a tribute to legendary filmmaker george
romero who never fully explained
why the zombies were reanimating in his
original living dead films
one of the key creatives behind the show
is greg nicotero
a long time hollywood veteran who has
more practical experience with zombies
than
just about anyone in the world nicotero
got his start working with zombies when
he joined the crew of george romero's
1985 film day of the dead
while there he worked with legendary
monster makeup artist tom savini
to help create undead horrors years of
experience have given nikitaro
innumerable opportunities to hone his
craft
soon after wrapping up work on day of
the dead nicotero dipped his toes into
many other iconic horror franchises
such as evil dead 2 nightmare on elm
street
halloween texas chainsaw massacre the
hills have
eyes and hostile among others but
nicotero didn't just
limit himself to horror films he also
did make up for spy kids the
adventures of shark boy and lava girl 3d
transformers
and the kill bill movies
throughout the series the walkers and
the walking dead are
fairly consistent beings they don't have
any wants
outside of flesh and their means of
finding food are limited to clumsily
biting what prey they manage to stumble
upon
aside from the sheer power presented by
a horde
walkers are simple creatures with no
intelligence
however while the walkers never stray
too far from being
mindless hunger driven creatures there
are some notable examples where they
display
some amount of intelligence specifically
the walkers in season one are
notably more resourceful than the
walkers in later seasons
for example morgan's undead wife
attempts to turn the doorknob to their
home before mindlessly bashing at the
front door
more impressively some walkers can be
seen using tools like
rocks to break into buildings
demonstrating that they're capable of
more advanced
problem-solving skills than just running
and biting victims
series creator robert kirkman provides
some insight in a reddit
ask me anything saying fresher zombies
which there were more of in season 1
can do more than older more rotted
zombies
in other words the walkers in season 1
are
newly minted and at their prime whereas
in later seasons they've started to rot
and
lose their physical and intellectual
capabilities
bringing the undead to life for tv is no
small
feat an underappreciated element of the
walking dead's walkers is the excessive
amounts of blood used to make them
all the more terrifying and realistic
special effects designer greg nicotero
told cbs news
the walking dead probably uses up the
most amount of blood
that we've ever had on any show i would
say per episode we're usually
somewhere in the 20 to 30 gallons range
but not all fake blood is created equal
nicotero explains that the blood is made
on set and depending on the scene varied
recipes are used for different effects
we have dark zombie blood we have dried
blood
we have coagulated blood if you have a
shirt like
my shirt which is dark and you want to
see the blood on it
it has to be brighter otherwise it would
just fade in with the color
nikitaro even revealed a surprising
ingredient in his blood concoction to
get the right consistency
in an interview with allure nicotero
admitted using ky
jelly as a thickening agent for the
blood
besides makeup and all other hands-on
aspects of creating walkers
there also exists the difficulty of
doing all of that work
justice by finding the best way in which
to film them
in an interview with digital trends greg
nicotero noted that the walking dead was
initially conceptualized in various
shooting formats
during the production of the first
season the series was tested using
panavision a red
digital camera and even 35 millimeter
film before the show runners ultimately
settled on the super 16 format
during a test using panavision a walker
was placed under green trees resulting
in the walker's makeup
looking green though color correction
could be used to solve the issue
nicotero and the walking dead production
team decided to use super 16
the medium that would result in the best
looking shot before color correction and
editing
for each episode of the walking dead the
necessity of special effects
is a given there's likely to be some
effects applied to background shots in
order to make a given shooting location
look
different characters are also sometimes
enhanced by
airbrushing blemishes adding sweat or
making bloody
oozing wounds more visceral any scene
with a walker getting stabbed with a
weapon will have a prop
extended to go through the shambling
corpse for the episodes that require a
hefty amount of effects it sometimes
takes quite a while to finish them
show runner and executive producer
angela kang
remarked from the start of an episode
getting locked
through the end of the vfx process it's
a weeks
long process on the short end like a
month
but really you want ideally at least a
couple months
to do it because the walking dead is
filmed in georgia the actors
crew and all of the extras are sometimes
subjected to
extreme weather temperatures in the
summer can reach well into the 90s with
humidity making everything feel hotter
during the colder months temperatures on
the set can sink below
freezing these intense filming
conditions have created
several complications for the special
effects masters of the show
according to makeup artist toby sells
traditional materials used in climate
sound stages such as gelatin melt in the
summer sun
the conventional wisdom led us to
finding a really big stage which we did
here at pinewood
and build multiple sets for the various
settings that takes place throughout the
script
some of the workarounds used to keep
extras and actors more comfortable are
pretty creative
for example david morrissey who played
the governor in the show's third
and fourth seasons had ice packs sewn
into his leather jacket
but nevertheless keeping everyone cool
and safe
is always a challenge as costume
designer yulin wobble explained
during the hotter days of filming
fighting the humidity
is the hardest part we have to keep the
zombies hydrated we have a medic
on staff if you see somebody who looks
dehydrated
you do whatever you have to do to keep
them comfortable
so what happens when the temperatures
drop
according to womble in winter we can
layer the zombies properly and we have a
snuggy wrangler
he literally runs out and puts snuggies
on the zombies when it's cold
with each new season the walkers become
noticeably more decomposed
as the apocalypse rages on it's only
natural that the undead would
continually fester away
however greg nicotero has expressed that
while the walkers may become
more visibly decayed there's a line in
the sand that the visual effects
and makeup teams are unwilling to cross
though the walking dead has been more
inclined to show sagging skin and
rotting flesh and newer seasons
the walkers will never decompose to the
point of becoming walking skeletons
in an interview with slash film nicotero
stated showrunner scott m gimple has
one very specific thing that he is
conscious of which is that it can't be a
ray harryhausen
it can't be a walking skeleton it always
has to be muscles it always has to be
something that is motivating the
movement
so while the walkers may grow more
ragged over time
walking dead fans can rest assured that
they'll never
wind up watching a modern day version of
jason and the argonauts
instead they'll get to appreciate all
the new ways that walkers will decompose
within the show's
self-imposed limit the most commonly
associated word with
undead people walking around is zombie
however the term is notably absent from
the walking dead
shedding some light on this discrepancy
in a conversation with conan o'brien
robert kirkman explained why the
characters never say
the word according to kirkman zombie
fiction simply doesn't exist in the
world he created
he explains we wanted to avoid that uh
notion of uh
hey why isn't that character just uh you
know shooting that zombie in the head
because it's all those movies i saw
as such the works of george romero the
creator of the living dead films
that established many tropes in the
modern zombie genre are
absent from the walking dead's world
kirkman further explains that without
romero's works the people within this
fictional realm have no
conceptualization of conventions and
rules
outlined in zombie media he states it
felt like having people not
use that word would kind of separate it
from that
make it a little bit more clear there
have always been a few
particularities that make the walking
dead seem a bit far-fetched
for example as the main cast treks
through the united states they seem to
regularly
be in short supply of firearm ammunition
but according to the
brookings institute over 400 million
guns are in the united states
likely with ammunition in vast
quantities as well
additionally the show's survivors are
frequently shown driving
years after the start of the apocalypse
despite regular gasoline degrading in
less than a year according to jd power
however there's been an even more
persistent trend that seems to run
counter to what one may expect in a
real-life zombie apocalypse situation
in the walking dead almost all of the
walkers are
skinny people this doesn't quite vibe
with the centers for disease control and
preventions data for georgia in 2019
which recorded that self-reported
obesity was at 33.1
given this disparity between real-life
demographics and
the population of the undead series
creator robert kirkman
offered an answer in a letter column for
the walking dead number 111
he wrote frankly it's hard to add to big
people to make them look like zombies
keep in mind to make those walkers look
real you have to
build stuff on top of real people
you start adding to people my size and
well you start to look a bit too padded
if that makes sense though rick and his
band of survivors typically use the word
walker to refer to each undead specimen
other names are offered throughout the
series
for instance the denizens of alexandria
refer to the walking corpses
as roamers others include rotters
as heard in season 5 and fighters as
they're called by the residents of
woodbury in season three
and of course there's also stinker the
nomenclature used by connie kelly luke
magna and yumiko in seasons 9
and 10. these varied alternatives to the
word
zombie coincide with kirkman's long time
tribute to romero who specifically
avoided the z
word in his living dead films as well
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about the
walking dead are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one